was deutschland gerade bevorsteht hat
israel schon hinter sich
ende september erreichte die zweite chor
ola wellen israel ihren höhepunkt
insbesondere ultra orthodoxe juden
stehen dabei in der kritik weil sie sich
nicht an die hygiene und abstandsregeln
halten
jetzt bereitet sich das land schon auf
die dritte welle vor mit strengen regeln
und wenn nötig harten strafen bei der
zweiten corona welle an deren ende wir
uns hier in israel befinden liegt unser
fokus hier im öffentlichen raum wir
achten darauf dass die menschen immer
und überall masken tragen
außerdem achten wir darauf dass der
mindestabstand eingehalten wird
das sind unsere regeln und vorschriften
wir sind der überzeugung dass die
ausbreitung von coop 19 verhindert
werden kann
wir bereiten uns damit schon auf die
dritte welle vor die wir für die
wintersaison
dezember und januar war wie schlimm die
dritte welle ausfallen wird liegt im
wesentlichen wie auch hierzulande in der
eigenverantwortung der menschen die
probleme ähneln die ihnen hierzulande
es gibt zwei hauptprobleme zum einen
müssen wir große hochzeiten verhindern
wo sich hierzulande leicht 200 bis 300
menschen versammeln
ein anderes problem stellen die ultra
religiösen jüdischen gemeinschaften da
auch dort gibt es große
menschenansammlungen was gegen unsere
coroner regeln verstößt
in beiden fällen kontrolliert die
polizei und unterbindet
massenversammlungen und hochzeiten um
die ausbreitung von coop 19 zu
verhindern
bei allen problemen mit denen die
polizei in jerusalem zu tun hat ist
fingerspitzengefühl gefragt wenn aber
alles reden nicht hilft drohen
empfindliche strafen
alles nicht nützt müssen wir strafen von
500 bis 5000 schekel gegen die
verantwortlichen verhängen
deswegen databases 5000 schekel
entsprechend etwa 1250 euro
ob diese geldstrafen religiöse eiferer
tatsächlich beeindrucken darf bezweifelt
werden
den polizisten von jerusalem stehen
weiterhin harte dienste bevor
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren